alors karim zéribi avant de vous poser
quelques questions à notre secrétaire
d'état qui nous fait le plaisir d'être
là ce soir moi j'ai une pensée quand
même ce soir monsieur le ministre je
pense que vous l'avez aussi pour le
personnel hospitalier
pour toutes ces aides soignantes et 6e
firme hier et ses docteurs et même ses
personnels et j'ai envie de dire qu'ils
entretiennent donc les hôpitaux parce
que ils sont sur le sur le feu depuis le
mois de février mars dernier de qu'il ya
une petite accalmie cet été mais là ça
repart puisqu'on a des hospitalisations
nouveau qui repartent et donc c'est un
personnel qui souvent eu le sentiment de
ne pas être considéré comme il se devait
donc j'espère que dans la durée le
gouvernement prendre en compte leurs
conditions de travail surtout leur
rémunération
ce que celle ci se doit d'être vraiment
revaloriser ce soir qu'est ce qu'on
entend on n'entend pas que le
gouvernement ne se soucie pas de la
situation
on est tout à fait conscient je crois
les uns des autres même ceux qui portent
des critiques de que la situation est
complexe
si une crise planétaire il n'y a pas un
pays qui donne l exemple de qui a su
s'en sortir
merveilleusement bien que tout le monde
a eu jamais de dire ces
dysfonctionnements et ses aspects
positifs
néanmoins il ya deux trois choses qui
ressorte monsieur le ministre et
j'aimerais bien que vous peut-être
répugné à ces interrogations d'abord un
il ya le souci de la cohérence chez nos
concitoyens et le gouvernement sur la
caisse sur la questure et sanitaire n'a
pas toujours donné le sentiment d'être
cohérent on est passé de le masquer sa
sert a rien au masque pour tous et
partout
c'est que max maintenant c'est la
semaine soit bien la crise ce grand
écart ça a été un marqueur le mazet dit
tout à l'heure un peu d'égalés change et
puis on n'a pas compris ce grand écart
pour tous et partout
quand on est seul dans la rue ont fini
le 20 ça tiraille mais non finalement ne
peut prendre une amende de sur la pas
bon ça c'est pas très cohérent donc dans
les espaces clos tout le monde comprend
qu'il faut le porter les français sont
prêts à respecter ce qu'ils comprennent
et pour ce faire je pense que ce qu'il
reproche aussi c'est le climat anxiogène
qui est créée autour de la copie 19 mai
on a l'impression qu'ils avaient
toujours dans le dans la dramatisation
on essaie c c'est la fin du monde on
peut pas vivre dans ce contexte là et
c'est assez contradictoire à la posture
du président la république qui dit il
faut qu'on s'habitue à vivre avec
mais si on doit s'habituer à vivre et
qu'on ne peut pas
vivre dans l'habitude je dirais de
l'anxiété c'est pas viable et ceux qui
ont en partie à des pressions qui vont
partir en stress de qui va se poser des
questions en permanence comment faire
pour dédramatiser
alors que c'est quand même un peu ce que
vous donnez parfois le sentiment de
faire et le ministre de la santé et le
premier ministre le président - ce que
le président a répété encore ces jours
ci je l'écoutais actuellement il faut
concilier l'économie et la santé il dit
que c'est possible aux paysans il y
croise il dit la confiance l'état
d'esprit ne conseille pas combien de
temps ça va durer six mois un an deux
ans donc il faut qu'on s'habitue
mais il nous dit faut qu'on s'habitue
tout en vivant pas en refusant de vivre
or parfois il ya des mesures qui donnent
le sentiment que la vie s'arrête mais
c'est pas possible on ne peut pas
imaginer un visage et que la vie
s'arrête de que quand on vous dit on
fermait salle de sport et des gens qui
comprennent pas ils se disaient ça dans
le sport qui respecte à la distanciation
c'est pas comme sports d'eau sur mars où
on a des corps à corps c'est ce que l'
usine à fait c'est une enseigne
parisienne et c'était le café le recours
et de kaki a réussi là de quoi remettre
en cause de l'arrêter parce que c'est
une salle de sport qui a pris les
mesures mais vous ne tenez pas compte
vous mettez salle de sport aux sports de
combat vous mettez tout de même paquet
ma restaurant pareil moi j'ai des amis
marseillais qui ont investi dans le
restaurant dominé plexiglas qui
respectent les distances sont dix
couverts ils en font que 50
il teste depuis mes pistes leurs
salariés matelot masque vous les avez
traité comme ceux qui respectaient pas
la fm paquet cadeau offert le tout ne
sont pas compris ils ont dit qu est ce
que c'est moi déjà j'ai du mal gm v6 et
derrière on me fait des assertions ça
revient beaucoup comme ceux qui ne
respectent pas est-ce que vous n'auriez
pas dû en ce sens renforcer le contrôle
on a dix sept mille contrôleurs de
l'urssaf est ce qu'on n'aurait pas dû
leur mettre une branche sanitaire pour
que tous les jours il a aidé les
établissements il vérifie et même dans
les salles de sport
pourquoi vous avez mis tout le monde
dans le même sac comme si personne
respecté les règles alors que la france
au mois de mars
quant aux vieilles confiné tout le monde
l'a respecté le confinement mais tout le
monde ait quelques options
quand vous dites le masque dans le métro
tout le monde ne le mets quand vous
dites le masque de qu'il faut le m 2 gla
les écoles les gamins le respecte un
moment donné je pense que vous avez
péché par manque de cohérence de clarté
de pédagogie ok vous
un climat anxiogène et les français
refusent de vivre dans un climat
anxiogène
quant aux autres médecins présents il
dit si le virus de la fête
je suis désolé mais c'est une expression
qui parle beaucoup plus que des grands
discours
quand vous initier le diffuseur a fait
moi je suis jeune je suis lycée ou sur
la fac je me dis bon les gars faut pas
qu on déconne l'arrêté gens nos potes de
que peut-être qu'il faut qu on soit un
peu moins à nendaz la fête mais ça ne
nous empêchera pas d'avoir des relations
sociales
là vous avez créé un climat qui n'est
pas claire qui n'est pas le comment
dirais-je et pédagogue et là encore une
fois je préférerais que vous mettiez à
une heure de grande écoute
un médecin qui dit les gars mais si le
virus de la fait arrêter sinon vous
allez vous comptez faire passer la main
avec les ce soir je pense que le message
en rien il est il est clair il est
simple avec des mots simples parfois le
politique qui complexifie les choses il
les rend compliqué de que il crée la
peur il crée la société
franchement monsieur le ministre vous
êtes jeunes peut-être que c'est à vous
aujourd'hui de prendre de la mangue donc
dans les messages qui sont passés au
gouvernement
avec des mots simples avec des mots
simples le miz la santé qui est arrivé à
marseille qui a dit dans 48 heures on
peut fermer les bars les nations comment
voulez vous que ce soit bien pris encore
une fois alors qu'il ya des gars qui
respectait pas il fallait la fermer
l'établissement et avaient été
respectées vous les avez fermé de la
même manière de combiner la 7e
république juste et équitable et un en
l'occurence ce soir j'en entends qui le
musée la santé avant de devenir qu'est
ce qui nous dit que la situation à paris
est aussi grave à marseille est-ce qu'il
a pris la mesure de fermeture des
restaurants la réponse est non
moi je m'en réjouis ils en pensent que
moi je suis pas devenu gardien
marseillais lundi
non il a dit il a dit nous prendrons la
décision lundi avec la mairesse de paris
dans les jours qui viennent en fonction
de la situation et il a précisé que la
profession lui faire des propositions
pour renforcer la distanciation les
gestes barrière donc maintenant on
écoute la profession et on écoute la
mairesse de paris à marseille j'avais
écouté ni le maire ni le président de
région ni le secteur d'activité ça fait
beaucoup
ça fait beaucoup donc si vous voulez que
les gens adhèrent il faut qu'ils
comprennent il faut qu'ils partagent
donc ils sont pas inconscients les
français ils ont respecté et là où cyril
a raison
quand on a dit on des copines on a vécu
ça comme une forme de libération c'est
ça on s'est dit allez on va retrouver
notre à l'hygiène de vie et non vous
auriez dû un moment donné lâchez les
choses petit à petit par étapes a là
aussi avec pédagogie de que à marseille
je suis désolé quand vous dites que cet
été vous êtes venu à marseille on avait
42 % de touristes dans la ville 40 % de
touristes qui ont été contaminés qui
sont repartis chez eux avec le virus
peut-être qu'on aurait dû à un moment
donné limiter les déplacements dans ce
décompte finement ok on va revivre un
peu comme avant on a retrouvé cette
terre qu'on a mis mais peut-être qu'on
va le faire de manière modérée voulait
pas fait de manière modérée
je suis désolé au début on a mis une
limite de déplacement à ses 1100 qu'il
juillet où vous le savez le soleil la
valette la mer suivons avec et vous
pensez quoi que les gens vont se réguler
tout seul je pense que les gens ils
peuvent comprendre qu'il faille poser
des limites
mais il faut leur expliquer il faut les
rassurer et il faut le faire avec des
mots simples
or vous êtes passé à côté de ces
messages là je précise juste une chose à
votre avantage
les mesures économiques et sociales que
vous avez prises je crois qu'il ya pas
un seul pays au monde qui les a prises
autant je suis critique sur les
questions sanitaires sur la manière dont
vous n'avez pas toujours été cohérent
sur les messages contradictoires ou qui
était absente de pédagogie autant ça
questions économiques et sociales
chômage partiel prêts garantis par
l'état reports de charges
il ya très peu de pays qui l'ont fait de
cancun ne font peut être critique son
gouvernement
mon peut aussi reconnaître que vous avez
fait des choses bien